und zwar haben wir hier ein wireless
charging pad das soll für alle iphones
funktionieren habe ich extra
durchgelesen also wenn das jetzt
funktioniert schließlich gewesen weil
das kann ich mir irgendwie überhaupt
nicht vorstellen
[Musik]
hey was geht ab im netz bekommen
bei einem neuen video ja da hätte ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut ich habe
ungefähr vor drei wochen in einem video
schon gesagt dass ich eigentlich mal
wieder extrem bock habe halt produkte zu
bestellen und die mit euch zu testen vor
der kamera das idol einer nicht ganz so
viele von euch gesehen deswegen hier
jetzt noch mal die frage habt ihr darauf
bock oder nicht schreibt einfach mal ja
oder nein in die kommentare oder gebt
einfach schnell nach oben auf jeden fall
habe ich in dem video auch gesagt dass
ich wiederwahl bayerisch bestellt habe
nach wirklich sehr sehr langer zeit ich
habe mich zehn kostenlose produkte
bestellt wovon irgendwie zwei immer noch
nicht angekommen sind aber ich habe
jetzt einfach keinen bock mehr zu warten
weil ich meine ich habe die vor einem
monat bestellt die sind jetzt da und das
zeug liegt halt schon die ganze zeit rum
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe
überhaupt keinen plan mehr was ich
bestellt habe deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht bevor ich da rein chef ne ich
das jetzt einfach mal mit euch so
missouri mäßig oder vielleicht fällt es
mir dann wieder ein wir haben ja die
jetzt einige pakete
und ich würde sagen wir öffnen die
einfach mal und schauen was das ganze an
ich kann mich noch an einen mp3-player
erinnern der dabei war halt gratis fand
ich schon krass und ich hoffe mal der
ist jetzt auch dabei ja das will den
jahren war gar nicht lange fangen wir an
ich würde einfach mal sagen wir fangen
mit diesem paket hier an ist auf jeden
fall sehr gut also im ersten paket haben
wir eine sonnenbrille die nichts
gekostet hat geht eigentlich gar nicht
mal so schlecht aus dann ist optimal
direkt aus also ich muss sagen die
qualität davon ist eigentlich recht gut
also ich bin gott wirklich so ein
bisschen von der qualität überrascht ich
hätte jetzt mit seiner brille gerechnet
die man halt mal im urlaub kauf für drei
euro und sie dann irgendwie wieder
verliert oder sie kaputt geht die
qualität ist schon echt gut und ich
glaube die sieht auch gar nicht so
schlecht aus wie könnt ihr mal gerne in
die kommentare schreiben steht mir diese
brille oder nicht weiß mir die brille
steht hashtag sonnenbrille also
keinesfalls ein schlechtes produkt jetzt
auf den ersten blick und das umsonst ich
würde sagen beschwerden kann man sich da
eher weniger wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten termin zum nächsten päckchen
waren diese socken drin steht drauf
damit ebenfalls umsonst
ich bin jemand ich weiß dass immer
einfach auseinander ob die mir passen
ist jetzt fragwürdig ich habe keine
sorgen ich ziehe lieber kurz an
ja also ich glaube die kann man wirklich
gut mit schuhen kombinieren kleinen
moment vielleicht denkt ihr euch jetzt
einfach mal andere schuhe dabei aber so
schlecht ist das gar nicht mehr die
qualität von den socken ist auch
eigentlich gut also ich muss sagen ich
bin gerade wirklich ein bisschen
überrascht ich habe früher sehr viel
dort bestellt das meiste war so ein
raumfahrzeug das schnell kaputt gegangen
ist oder wo man mit der qualität jetzt
nicht besonders zufrieden sein konnte
aber die socken und die sonnenbrille
beides topleute in diesem paket ist ein
laser drin und zwar habe ich einen
kostenlosen laser gefunden war
eigentlich zufall ich habe
ich glaube ich damals irgendwann youtube
video gesehen wo jemand mit einem laser
rast gemacht habe und ich war das ganz
lustig und hat mir gedacht von bestellte
der amazon ding da will ich jetzt gerne
ein extra video zu machen also ein
gratis laser von wish wenn ihr darauf
bock gehabt beschreibt es gerne in die
kommentare
dann kommt das morgen oder übermorgen
mal sehen war hat einfach so eine idee
wir machen wollten mit dem nächsten
päckchen jo leute hier haben wir
irgendwie so creme ich kann mich noch
daran erinnern dass ich die bestellt
habe die es irgendwie ganz besonders aus
china schaut euch das gern wir hier an
die soll nämlich ich kann euch das mal
kurz einblenden glaube ich wunden extrem
schnell heilen ich muss sagen die
richter extrem schlimm so nachdem wenn
man die jetzt auf die haut ist es alles
andere als gut die muss ich war mal
wieder zu machen da kriege ich
kopfschmerzen top hinein moment wir
machen davon mal was auf die haut mal
guckt ob irgendwas passiert ich gehe
jetzt nicht davon aus ich mache mal hier
auf dem arm und schnell wieder zu ich
glaube das hat irgendwas mit pferden zu
tun kein plan wir machen schnell weiter
mit dem nächsten zug wird die alte
trasse mit kopfhörern leute wir haben
hier ein mp3-player einmal das gerät an
sich mit kopfhörern
die frage ist kriegt man da irgendwie
musik drauf ja mit einer micro sd noch
mal kurz ein bisschen musik drauf und
stehe das dann ab also wenn das jetzt
funktioniert fresse ich einen besen weil
das kann ich mir irgendwie überhaupt
nicht vorstellen habe ich mir schon fast
gedacht poetry kann also hier muss sich
jetzt leider sagen mp3 player
funktioniert überhaupt nicht es gleich
mal ob diese kopfhörer wenigstens gehen
ich meine ich glaube hier fehlt auch
eine batterie oder so das ding das ist
extrem leicht eigentlich schade aber
auch selbst erwarten ich meinen kostet
halt nichts machen wir weiter mit dem
nächsten klicken
und zwar haben wir hier etwas fürs ohr
ich habe mal auf diese scheiß creme
drauf passiert überhaupt nichts mit habe
ich mir aber auch gedacht und wie das
jetzt funktioniert bzw was das sein soll
das hält nicht mal meinem ort überhaupt
einer was ist das für eine scheiße ich
habe keine ahnung was es sein soll
wir müssen das glaube ich mal kurz
nachgucken am pc was ich da genau
bestellt war
heute übrigens dieses produkt fehlt noch
diese fashion label sexy underwear für
zwei personen und hier haben wir nur
mini inklusive ultra small bluetooth
stereo ach so das ding soll also
anscheinend bluetooth haben was ich
irgendwie als relativ unwahrscheinlich
einstufe
weil das wiegt auch überhaupt gar nichts
ihr könnt ja mal kurz testen auch hier
muss ich jetzt leider sagen das bringt
zwar rot also das ding ist an das soll
jetzt blut haben ich weiß nicht ob ich
jetzt hier auch wieder irgendwas falsch
mache ich gehe aber davon aus dass es
nicht so ist weil man sieht hier es wird
nichts gefunden ich habe das schon öfter
versucht das einzige was man nicht
machen kann es kirschkernweitspucken in
der zeit packen wir aber weiter aus ich
habe hier noch irgendwas alles besteht
aus irgendwelchen kabel aha da weiß ich
was das ist und zwar haben wir ein
wireless charging pad das soll für alle
iphones funktionieren habe ich extra
durchgelesen
das heißt hier kommt das ding rein und
jetzt brauchen wir noch einen adapter
und dann versuche ich mal mein iphone
hier drauf zu laden
auch wenn ich die chance dass das klappt
als sehr sehr gering einstufte wir
werden es sehen
das mache ich am ende erst packen wir
noch weiter aus und zwar haben wir hier
noch ein paket habe ich auch kein plan
das waren schon leute sieht aus wie eine
nach dass so ein apfel sein
ich bin dumm ich weiß es ist ganz
einfach man tut den apfel drauf drückt
ihm durch und schon hat man dann
geschichten apfel oder man setzt es
einfach sich selber auf die nase und
sieht aus wie ein auto gar nicht mal so
schlecht
gut also wir haben jetzt einige sachen
ausgepackt ganz wichtig als versuchen
noch kurz herauszubekommen ob denn
dieses ding funktioniert und ich damit
wirklich mein iphone laden kann wenn das
klappt komme ich glaube ich wirklich
mehr klappt mein leben weil dann müssen
wir mal bedenken das ist sowas in china
schon wird das produkt kam aus china
in deutschland aber eher nicht so
wirklich zumindest kostet das dann so
weit ich weiß relativ viel das ding war
grad ist liegt auch überhaupt gar nichts
aber er weiß wir probieren es also wenn
das jetzt klappen
ich musste erst mal noch kurz diese
scheiße hier abbrechen so wir haben hier
einen usb-adapter da kommt das rein
jetzt kann man hier sogar diese rote
lampe leuchten sehen also es sollte an
sein und jetzt lege ich mal mein iphone
drauf
ich lasse es mal kurz darauf liegen aber
es geht halt nicht bei also entweder ich
möchte jetzt irgendwas falsch schreibt
es gerne in die kommentare falls das so
ist aber ich hätte mich auch extrem
gewundert wenn das funktioniert weil er
hätte ich meine ladekabel in müll
geschmissen schade eigentlich also leute
was man jetzt so als kleines fazit
ziehen kann also ich habe insgesamt wie
schon gesagt elf produkte bestellt davon
sind zwar immer noch nicht da ich finde
es echt immer witzig und auch cool dass
es so seiten gibt die halt kostenlose
produkte anbieten
ich meine es müde sicher auch andere
über einem youtube-video zu machen haben
ja auch schon leute vor mir gemacht mein
fazit wer jetzt nur wenn ihr euch da
irgendwas bestellt man muss ja mal
versand zahlen deswegen würde ich sagen
bestellt euch am besten nichts was mit
technik zu tun hat weil er aus erfahrung
kann ich sagen gut wenn man da jetzt 20
30 euro investiert oder ein handy dann
ist das ein handy das ist okay damit
kann man arbeiten es ist jetzt nichts
krasses aber es ist schon krass dass man
für so günstiges geld und handy bekommen
was fähig ist whatsapp zu nutzen und so
weiter so kleine cage ist wie zum
beispiel diese bluetooth kopfhörer oder
der mp3 player für umsonst funktioniert
überhaupt nicht keine ahnung warum sowas
dann angeboten wird aber gut aber
ausfallen mal so sonnenbrillen oder so
kostenlos zu bestellen bleibt auf jeden
fall spaß kann ich empfehlen heute dann
würde ich sagen und das war es erstmal
mit diesem video zehn kostenlose ruhig
produkte ich glaube es waren jetzt nur
neun weil halt zwei fehlten und ich elf
bestellt habe ausgepackt ich hoffe
natürlich es hat euch gefallen
falls ja und ihr bock drauf habt so ich
früher das öfter noch mal was von wish
kommt oder anderen shops lassen doch
nach oben da wir sehen uns dann
spätestens übermorgen wieder da gibt es
was cooles von amazon und 3 bis dann